ah
[Música]
el ecuador concluye toque 2020 con su
mejor participación en unos juegos
olímpicos abriendo una nueva página de
su historia deportiva dos medallas de
oro y una de plata ubicado al país en la
posición número 38 del medallero general
medicina jóvenes de 23 años y cámaras al
azar se colgaron el oro y la plata en la
especialidad de halterofilia levantando
163 kilos mientras que la locomotora del
carchi campeón del giro de italia 2019 y
tercero del tour de francia' 2021
richard cara paz también devolvió la
esperanza al país con una medalla de oro
en el ciclismo ecuador todavía mantiene
vivo el recuerdo de hace 25 años con la
única medalla olímpica que se conocía en
el país andino o la victoria del
marchista jefferson pérez en
atlanta-1996 la participación de ecuador
en los juegos olímpicos trae un balance
positivo que motiva no sólo los atletas
sino a todo un país se incrementó de 25
por ciento las disciplinas en las que
participó el ecuador pasando de 12 a 15
una justa deportiva internacional en
comparación al río 2016 de 38 a 48
atletas ecuatorianos se logra la
presencia de deportistas en el ciclo
olímpico siete nuevos diplomas contables
del país en la cita deportiva acumulando
34 puntos aún y que no está acostumbrado
al júbilo internacional
[Música]
méxico concluyó su participación en los
olímpicos de tokio 2020 con solo cuatro
medallas todas ellas de bronce en lo que
ha sido la peor cosecha de preseas en el
siglo 21 pues desde sydney 2000 hasta
rio 2016
méxico no se había ido sin un oro una
plata en tokio los bronces fueron en
clavados fútbol halterofilia femenil y
tiro con arco sin embargo no es la peor
actuación de méxico en juegos olímpicos
y en su propio ranking de peores
desempeños ocuparía la novena posición
desde parís 1924 los críticos atribuyen
el poco éxito a los malos manejos de las
federaciones y la falta de apoyo a los
atletas no obstante al margen del
medallero hubo destacadas actuaciones y
se consiguieron siete cuartas posiciones
entre ellas softball clavados y una de
las más aplaudidas el salto de caballo
con álex amore
[Música]
y
la delegación de venezuela culminó su
presentación en los juegos olímpicos de
tokio 2020 con cuatro medallas una de
oro y tres de plata además de obtener
seis diplomas así venezuela vivió sus
mejores juegos en la historia del
olimpismo y logró ubicarse en la casilla
número 46 del medallero además la reina
del salto triple yulimar rojas logró
romper récord mundial para venezuela la
medalla de oro de yolimar las de plata
de julio mayor ahí que y domar
vallenilla en pesas y la de daniel dhers
en pm x fueron las responsables de las
buenas noticias para venezuela estos
resultados se dan luego de un
accidentado ciclo olímpico con problemas
de financiamiento que muchos atletas
venezolanos denunciaron en su momento
[Música]